hey what's up guys welcome to another HD
video this one is actually an unboxing
video as you can see by the title if I
can get that right up by the title this
is a handstand esscom review now once
again this video i did that the box is a
little bit big for the other video frame
itself but i'll do my invest my best to
get this out of your way so you can
actually see what's in here so the link
to the company that was kind enough to
send this out to me ham stands calm is
in the description so check that they
were kind enough to send me this product
for a review purposes only so not only
but i do get to keep this but this is a
great great company and a great product
that they sent me so they ship this one
phenix which is very very good it came
halfway across the country in two and a
half days so large box so you know i'm
just gonna take this out of you guys
care you all right that's not the way
this is the ham stands calm laptops and
now first of all you'll notice if i can
get this wide screen but it's still
going to be a little bit tight there
this is the laptop stand it is the I
desk right here this is basically
turning your laptop into a desk by as
you can see a little angle to it this is
available at ham stands calm 439 dot 99
right now and I'm just going to take it
out of the blocks the only con right out
of the box is that it's a little bit
steep just deep enough so that you're
going to have to use a I'm going to have
to use an external keyboard in order to
type with this so I'm actually going to
change the camera angle to a little
different one so we can see such a big
box and unbox this thing so here we go
alright guys we've migrated to the floor
here and I know it might be a little bit
of glare but i will see if we can get
this to work it is a pre pub it's light
but it's a pretty big box so on this
side it just says in the top corner ACI
desk and i can see a full full on view
of it now on the side they have four
pictures they have one of actually
setting it up six gears of adjustable
height
can one is showing with an external
keyboard third one is actually typing on
it propped up and the fourth is showing
what is that separable models separable
modules extend to other supplements
functions a 427 port USB 2.0 hub okay so
we're getting a little USB hub throw in
there that's very cool so let's go ahead
and actually open the the entire box
[ __ ] enough pull that out put on a
camera so I don't really need the knife
for good and looks like in the top right
here we got some styrofoam so I'm just
going to slide this out that was
interesting so we don't need this box
anymore that's going to be off camera
and what you see here is styrofoam we
got some things in the box the first
thing we have right here is a quick
start guide that shouldn't really be
necessary we know how to you you know
use a laptop stand a little instructions
for how to look at it but basically yeah
that's the quick start guide right here
we have a USB 2.0 cable which is further
evidence that there may actually be a
USB 2.0 of he's going here's the stand
itself all right it's not going to look
like a stand at first guys and there's
more styrofoam but here is the span its
first impressions now guys it's plastic
okay this is how it will actually look
when it's on your desk you're not going
to see the white part but it says I desk
got a little branding on the front the
actual basically the actual tilt of it
oh there we go there's the USB ho
there's a four port USB hub in the back
and we have a little power adapter I
don't know if you can there's the light
but that's the power adapter and the
actual USB plug in now I might actually
need a quick start guide because I'm not
exactly sure how to adjust the height I
keep going off camera guys but there you
go i will show you guys obviously in a
full review video you will be able to
see the laptop inside of this it'll be
able to accommodate like it says on
their website check it out a 17 inch
laptop so that's cool so yeah basically
i'm going to get you guys on a the full
review of it how to use the tilting and
everything and if you're looking looking
into buying a cool
and or a stand for a laptop then this is
going to be the one for you so this has
been another HD video from mkbhd I hope
you enjoyed this unboxing video and I
thank you for watching this one stay
tuned for the floor video full review
video guys these